fillon les jeunes qui sont au coeur d'un
problème de santé de plus en plus
évoquée l'obésité
un enfant sur cinq serait trop gros et
parmi les cas d'obésité sont en nombre
croissant
question peut-on régler le problème par
la loi c'est ce que propose un député
socialiste jean marie le guen son texte
préconise notamment une demi heure
quotidienne de sport et des fontaines
d'eau dans tous les établissements
isabelle quintard guillaume vient à
chaque fois que sa grand mère vient
chercher jules 8 ans c'est le même
cérémonial le passage par la boulangerie
c'est pas méchant en fait un croissant
pour les jours il vaut mieux aller
marche m
et manger moins peut-être car les
gâteaux et les enfants c'est une
histoire d'amour qui peut parfois mal
finir quand l'enfant a cumulé kg et
devient obèse jean-marie le guen député
ps et médecin a proposé une loi avec
différentes mesures parmi lesquelles
installer une fontaine à eau dans chaque
établissement scolaire faire 30 minutes
d'activité physique par jour peser
mesurer les enfants aux différentes
étapes de la croissance et enfin la
possibilité d'interdire la publicité
télévisée sur ce dernier thème le député
est très clair si on est chocolatier je
considère qu'il est parfaitement logique
de vendre du chocolat et je n'ai en tant
que du point de vue de la santé publique
et il n'y a aucune opposition à ce que
l'on puisse manger du chocolat
mais prétendre que l'on doit manger tous
les jours et plusieurs fois par jour du
chocolat et le prétendre par sa démarche
commerciale ou le sous-tendre par sa
démarche commerciale
ça c'est effectivement une dérive qui
n'est pas acceptable pour ce
nutritionniste légiférer sur l'obésité
c'est un constat d'échec et cela ne
changera pas grand chose on peut pas
arrêter l'explosion l'obésité qu'on
observe actuellement on pourra l'arrêter
peut-être que dans deux trois
générations
le mouvement ne s'inversera que dans
deux trois générations et je ne suis pas
où nous en disant ça mais lancement tous
les chiffres sont en train de le prouver
donc on va continuer à dégrader quelles
que soient les mesures prises pas
continuer à dégrader notre poids pour
les années qui viennent
6 en france l'obésité grignote du
terrain le nombre d'enfants atteints
double ainsi que tous les 15 ans et il
ya actuellement plus de 5 millions de
français dans cette situation